los dos fueron ministros en gobiernos de
benjamin netanyahu pero ahora ya lápiz y
nafta live net son los artífices de la
coalición israelí construida para
destronarlo y señor presidente le llamó
para decir que logre formar un gobierno
con esta llamada del 2 de junio el
centrista yair lapid anunciaba que había
logrado lo imposible agrupar 8 partidos
de la oposición para darle a israel un
primer ministro distinto a netanyahu por
primera vez en 12 años la pide es líder
del partido y es a ti la segunda fuerza
después del likud la formación de
netanyahu una de sus banderas es la
lucha contra la corrupción adecuada para
confrontar a un netanyahu investigado
por soborno y fraude
la vida ha sido el principal constructor
de esta insólita coalición que agrupa
desde ideologías de extrema derecha
hasta partidos pacifistas o partidos
árabes
pero sus esfuerzos hubieran sido en vano
si naftalí bennett líder del partido ya
mina no hubiera sumado sus siete escaños
claves a la coalición
bennett ex ministro de defensa bajo las
órdenes de netanyahu se presentó con una
propuesta ultranacionalista dispuesta a
renovar la política israelí
más allá lo que era ya no será lo más
considerado aliado natural de netanyahu
decidió darle la espalda para unirse a
unos socios improbables para cumplir con
su objetivo de romper con el pasado pero
le puso un alto precio a su apoyo ser
primer ministro durante los primeros dos
años de gobierno de la coalición